he's an award-winning magician dazzling
audiences every single night at the link
and an incredible partnership with the
animal foundation matt franco so excited
to have you on the show this morning now
i know you're not going to do any magic
tricks what we'd love is to have all the
dogs disappear and go to good homes not
disappear but go eat transport if you
will transfer them to good homes which
is exactly what happened with your new
pooch here gecko yes from the animal
foundation yes how did this happen so
about once a month or twice a month the
animal foundation will actually bring an
animal from the foundation to the matt
franco theater on like a little field
trip oh okay we've been doing this since
the before the pandemic so they started
back up again and the very first dog
they brought over was gekko
and i was just completely smitten by him
and i said i think we'd like to foster
gekko
and that lasted about two days you were
a foster fail of course yeah and then
the next thing you know we're at the
animal foundation saying yeah we're
gonna have to keep him even though we
didn't plan on it because we already
have four other pets at home so now it's
five
and uh he's just the best he's an old
man 10 years old
and we love him well you were an animal
lover and i know this is um is this your
fifth year partnering with the animal
foundation to try to help all the pets
that are at the animal foundation
waiting for their forever home tell
folks exactly what you're doing and how
they can get involved sure it's great
because not everyone is in a situation
where they
can foster or can adopt another animal
or an animal right now so
what we do is give an opportunity for
people to go to any petsmart in las
vegas
and they can buy something off the shelf
okay it goes into a donation box you
can't miss it it's got my face on it
and uh those go to the animal foundation
but in return for doing that you
actually get a ticket to come to see the
show oh hey it's a twofer it it really
is a win-win yeah we've been doing this
um this is our fifth time around we've
raised over twenty thousand dollars
worth of supplies in the past and uh
we're looking to
get do some more because the animal
foundation always could use the help so
whether it's blankets or dog toys or
food or gift cards you go to the
petsmart you pick it up it goes in the
box which goes directly to the animal
foundation in return you get that
voucher to come see me we actually
reserve some really great seats for
people who participate in this wonderful
but yeah you can get picked from
anywhere in my show it doesn't matter if
you're in the front row or the back row
i choose people from all over and uh
yeah it's a really great iteration of
the show right now because we recently
revamped it right before right uh before
reopening okay so it's uh if you haven't
been since before the pandemic there are
is new stuff to see and i've got more
new stuff on the way so it's good to
catch it now before 2023 with more new
stuff on the way your magic always just
has me
just in oh thank you it's so fun matt
and gekko thank you for coming on the
show today we appreciate it folks go to
the animal foundation well go to
petsmart help out the animal foundation
and go see matt yeah absolutely thank
you thank you i'm giving him a treat so
that's what i'm doing
making that treat disappear yeah